so just everything is going wrong for
donald trump i think you're going to
like this one
we talked yesterday about the great
developments in terms of the coronavirus
vaccine the vaccine being developed by
pfizer
was announced yesterday to have a 90
effectiveness in a large clinical trial
has not yet been peer reviewed but it
looks very good
donald trump immediately tried to attach
his name to it immediately tweeting in
all caps
stock market up big vaccine coming soon
report 90 percent effective such great
news
vice president mike pence also weighed
in and he just straight up tried to take
credit for it
he tweeted huge news thanks to the
public
private partnership forged by trump
pfizer
announced its coronavirus vaccine trial
is effective
preventing infection in 90 of its
volunteers
this is all made up and in fact it's
such nonsense that pfizer's head of
vaccine research
immediately clarified we took no money
from trump's so-called
operation warp speed katherine janssen
head of vaccine research at pfizer told
the new york times
we have never taken any money from the
u.s government she also told the new
york times that pfizer
was never part of operation warp speed
it's actually hilarious
that trump and pence are trying to
crowbar their way
into this and as reported by bloomberg
quote
among the front runners theirs is the
only
vaccine project that did not take
funding from the white house led
operation warp speed program
to bolster research development or
manufacturing
you like almost start to feel just the
tiniest bit sorry for these
people but we actually don't because
they keep insisting
they won uh but but biden did fraud and
all this different stuff
no that's not true okay but now they say
we got
we got the vaccine done because we gave
pfizer money well no
pfizer didn't take any money from you
okay well something
something and they get nothing there's
actually even more hilarity to this
which is that this is really a german
vaccine work on this vaccine
started in germany in january because
the ceo
of bioentech which is the partner
company with pfizer that developed the
vaccine
the ceo of bioentech read about the
virus in the lancet
and realized this is going to be huge so
they immediately started working on the
vaccine meanwhile trump in january was
saying oh we've got this completely
under control
it's one person from china it's going to
be fine trump's saying in
was it march 15 cases or maybe even
april 15 cases will soon be zero
that's why this vaccine is now almost
ready because in germany when trump was
doing nothing
they started working on it donald trump
and mike pence
are trying to take credit for a vaccine
but it was actually a vaccine developed
in germany
by a german company founded by turkish
immigrants
produced in the us by a company that
took
no money from donald trump's operation
warp speed
that's the truth don't let the door hit
you on the way out guys
we'll have continued coverage of the
vaccine make sure you're following me on
twitter
where you can find me at d pacman
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health and get
personalized care
from the comfort of your home it's a
service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything and
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video